sont des experts qui avaient pour
mission non pas d'entendre monsieur
péché mais de travailler sur le dossier
de savoir si ce qu'il avait dit ou ce
qu'il ce qu'il pouvait dire au téléphone
ou ce qu'il avait dit lors de ses
auditions permettait de trouver dans sa
personnalité des éléments qui soit en
faveur ou pas est ce qu'on peut avoir le
fois dans ce type de rapport vous avez
affaire à deux experts judiciaires qui
ont prêté serment qui sont les experts
reconnus par la justice qui sont sur une
liste judiciaire et je vois pas pourquoi
on devrait le contester moi j'ai pas de
difficultés je dis pas que c'est une
preuve matérielle
simplement c'est une petite pierre de
plus à l'édifice de l'accusation
simplement la force de rajouter les
petites pièces je crains que de coeur
pesci soit étouffée sous des caillous
qu'est ce que vous retenez dans ce
rapport je retiens ni totalement
psychologique ni criminologique il et
psycho criminologique voilà oui ils
étaient deux et je retiens tout
simplement une chose c'est que la
personnalité de monsieur peschier est en
totale adéquation avec la nature des
faits criminels qui lui sont reprochés à
savoir à savoir de quelqu'un qui est
narcissique quelqu'un qui dans la toute
puissance quelqu'un qui est intelligent
et quelqu'un qui est froid
la défense fait état d'études
psychiatrique elle qui sont complètement
donc ils reprochaient strictement rien
au docteur poche et qui vont à
l'encontre presque parce que c'est
normal c'est pas la même chose
une experte chez 4x est de savoir si la
personne est atteinte ou non d'un
trouble une maladie mentale
personne n'a dit que monsieur pesci et
est atteint d'une maladie mentale
je sais que c'est pas le cas si c'était
le cas il serait irresponsable
pénalement personne ne dise à dire quand
on compare des fraises et un shu ça n'a
rien à voir mais ça s'appelle un
couvre-feu ouais on essaie un pare-feu
on essaie d'ouvrir des contre-feux on
essaie de détourner l'attention
sauf que premièrement les rapports dont
il est fait état ils sont pas encore au
dossier de l'instruction
donc moi je veux bien qu'on fasse parler
des choses qui ne soit pas encore rentré
dans le dossier et puis deuxièmement ça
n'a rien à voir la psychiatrie n'est pas
la psycho criminologie ça n'a rien à
voir
moi j'ai mon opinion personnelle qui est
fait depuis le début je vais vous dire
elle est tranchée à l'éclair la défense
la conteste c'est son droit le plus
absolu
mais si le dossier était si vide que
cela est bien pourquoi la défense fait
tout pour retarder ou pour empêcher un
procès si véritablement ils ont
confiance en leurs dossiers et bien que
nous allions nous expliquer publiquement
il veut que ce soit public nous aussi
contradictoires ans c'est plus facile
c'est un peu un peu plus réaliste que
devant une caméra
et puis on va contradictoirement échangé
les points et les autres du dossier et
puis nous verrons ce qu'en penseront les
jurés de la cour d'assises
parce que la défense critique les
magistrats les enquêteurs l'accusation
les experts maintenant les enquêteurs
enfin d'accord c'est bien beau de
critiquer tout le monde allons devoir un
jury de cour d'assises
et puis faisons lui confiance